a Donald Trump KKK parade is being
planned in North Carolina for December
3rd this is the North Carolina Ku Klux
Klan they are being really emboldened
and want to celebrate Donald Trump's
election as president of the United
States because they clearly feel like
Donald Trump is sort of their kind of
guide I told you earlier in the show
former KKK leader David Duke he is
really happy with Steve Bannon being
selected as one of Donald Trump's
closest aides he is calling Donald
Trump's victory quotes victories one of
the most exciting nights of my life and
early on in the Republican primaries
David Duke was wholeheartedly supporting
Donald Trump Trump was reluctant to
reject the support initially he
pretended he didn't know who David Duke
was earlier videos showed that clearly
he did know who David Duke was he
eventually said yeah I don't want his
support but there's a really simple case
to be made you know
Trump again he denounced David Duke from
daughter Ivanka is Jewish Trump's
grandkids are Jewish but that does not
change the reality that Trump has
catalyzed the KKK he is catalysed white
supremacy in a way no recent major
political candidate has done I'm
wondering whether four groups like the
KKK this is even really about supporting
Trump this could be more and I was
thinking about this over the weekend Pat
this could be more about white
nationalists saying okay yeah we're
gonna we don't like the Trump's daughter
is Jewish and Trump seems to have no
problem with it we don't like the
Trump's grandkids are Jewish and Trump
seems to have no problem with it but we
are going to use Trump's election as an
opportunity to really scare minorities
by doing things like having a parade in
North Carolina when's the last time you
heard of a KKK having a parade in order
to try to induce minorities to get
agitated and maybe violent as a pretext
for violence against minorities I know
that it's a little something else than
what's being discussed but you'd think
they'd know that Trump has numerous
direct ties to Jewish individuals and
seems to have no personal problem with
Jews and it's interesting to see how
Trump will respond to this if he'll
denounce it or ignore it because
something really irks Donald Trump he'll
take to Twitter over it yeah that's what
we see what the protesters going on now
but if he just flat-out ignores this
it's kind of giving a wink and a nod to
it let's review what I've been saying
for a while now which is the scariest
part about Trump is partially who Trump
is embolden encoder pluribus that are
now emboldened and feel like there were
a legitimate part of the national
discussion and it includes people like
David Duke it includes the KKK even if
most Americans don't see them as a
legitimate part of the national
conversation the fact that one candidate
has so catalyzed them should not be
ignored and we're not going to ignore it
and clearly civil rights groups aren't
ignoring it because it's having
real-world consequences